let's say that f of x
is equal to two x minus three
and g of x
g of x
is equal to one half x
plus three what i want to do in this
video is evaluate what f of g of x is
f of g of x and then i want to evaluate
what g of f of x is so first i want to
evaluate f of g of x
and then i'm going to evaluate the other
way around i'm going to evaluate g of f
x but let's evaluate f of g of x person
like always encourage you to pause the
video and see if you can work through it
so this is going to be equal to f of g
of x is going to be equal to well
wherever we see the x in our definition
for f of x the input now is g of x so
we'd replace it with the g of x it's
going to be 2 times g of x
2 times g of x minus 3
minus 3
and this is going to be equal to 2 times
well g of x is all of that business
2 times
1 half x
plus 3
and then we have the minus 3
minus 3. and now we can distribute this
2
2 times 1 half x is just going to be
equal to
x
2 times 3 is going to be 6 so x plus 6
minus 3. and so this is going to be
this is going to equal
x plus 3
x plus 3. all right interesting that's f
of g of x now let's think about what g
of f of x is going to be
so g
of
our input instead of being instead of
calling our input x we're going to call
our input f of x
so g of f of x
is going to be equal to
is going to be equal to
one half
times our input which in this case is f
of x
one half times f of x plus three
plus
three you can view the x up here is the
placeholder for whatever our input
happens to be and now our input is going
to be f of x and so this is going to be
equal to one-half times what is f of x
it is 2x minus 3.
so 2 times x minus three and then we
have a plus three
and now we can distribute the one half
one half times two x is going to be x
one half times negative three is
negative three halves
and then we have a plus three
so let's see three is the same thing as
six halves so six halves minus three
halves is going to be three halves so
this is going to be equal to x plus
three halves
so notice
we definitely got different things for f
of g of x and g of f of x and we also
didn't do a round trip we didn't go back
to x so we know that these are not
inverses of each other in fact we just
have to do either this or that to know
that they're not inverses of each other
so these are not inverses so let me
write it this way
f of x
f of x does not equal
does not equal the inverse of g of x
does not equal the inverse of g of x and
g of x
does not equal the inverse of f of x
does not equal the inverse of f of x in
order for them to be inverses if you
have an x value right over here and if
you apply g to it if you input it into g
and then that takes you to g of x
so that takes you to g of x right over
here so that's the function g and then
you apply f to it you would have to get
back to the same place so g inverse
g inverse would get us back to the same
place
and clearly we did not get back to the
same place we didn't get back to x we
got back to x plus 3.
same thing over here we see that we did
not get by we did not go get back to x
we got back to or we we got to x plus 3
hat so they're definitely not inverses
of each other